hello good people of the Internet I'm
Dave Rubin this is the Rubin report and
you're most likely watching on the
internet so we have to move fast because
you got porn open and okay here we go
so Egypt what was once one of the great
countries of the world
things have been not going as well as
they did say 2,000 years ago or so their
top satirist the guy who's known as the
Egyptian Jon Stewart I want to get his
name right Bassam Yosef he was arrested
for guess what
providing satire he's since been
released for about 2,500 bucks and
before we get that far into it let's
let's take a look a little bit of that
satire Mohammed Morsi the Isthmus Nana
is still cool an attender Hanafi other
article and a shahira I mean
he truly is I mean he's doing a Jon
Stewart if Jon Stewart was not Jewish
that would be his gig all right so I
want to talk about what is going on in
Egypt and you know we had the whole
Egyptian revolution and everything but
things seem to be worse than when they
started
bill I'm gonna start with you what is
the deal in Egypt I don't know but I
think that bringing that kind of you
know dictatorial scrutiny to to humor
would make it a lot more interesting to
watch because anything that you say
you're willing to risk your you know
your freedom for and your and your life
for you know it better be funny I think
the fact that we have so much freedom in
this country and that you know the our
our Constitution guarantees us the right
to say anything it's it's too much of a
free fall and there's a lot of times
when I'm watching certain sketches on TV
certain comedians a lot of SNL stuff and
you're like man these people need to be
called on a part of it they needed
request at least question and release so
that they get their their game together
they they should have to answer for some
of their their treasonous attempts at
humor yeah
Sam what do you think you're a satirist
a comedy person when you're doing pop
trigger do you feel that the
government's gonna come get you we don't
and I tell you what we wouldn't say half
of the things 99 percent of the things
on pop trigger if we believed that
especially some of my co-hosts that we
get on the show we have a lot of
comedians that come in the showbread
Ehrlich's on the show and we speak
exactly what we feel and you look at
some of the you know the comedian's
today I mean they can actually you know
they can celebrate the president or our
government or they can hate on it and we
see that with you know a lot of the
people in Fox News we see that with Rush
Limbaugh can you imagine if the same
rules applied here we'd have a lot of
people locked up yeah yeah it seems to
me that comedy actually is sort of the
first thing that should come around in a
democracy they need this in Egypt
tremendously where do you think this
will fall out I mean do you think that
he will go back and do it again where
has he now been scared enough to just
forget offensive as this is to Egypt
Egypt's long line of satirist and the
distinguished lineage there
I'm not um how far back is that about
three years if or six months yeah you
know give or take your how you're
measuring it I'm not really very
concerned I think that you know that the
trajectory that we see Egypt long you
know playing along is going to really
lead to you know more open dialog and
you know Americans when we look back at
our own history and our own and a fight
for freedom and and how we and you know
how we went from you know authoritarian
rule to you know doing things on our own
yeah it's kind of we kind of wash over
some of the some of the you know that
the problems in the dirt that comes
along with going from authoritarianism
to a democracy and there's just some of
the growing pains that any situation you
know any situation like this will you
know will encounter and I think you're
gonna find the Egyptian Stephen Colbert
and the Egyptian Millbrook soon enough
and they can all be in jail together
apparently perhaps well I'm glad you
brought up the growing pains actually
because what do you guys think I mean it
seemed like they had a dictator and not
seemed like it was they had a dictator
in Egypt for about thirty years then
they had this Arab Spring thing and now
they have the Muslim Brotherhood who
really is more extreme than Mubarak was
in the first place so how long does it
take to get freedom well I mean like you
said I think I think you brought up a
really interesting point that you know
this doesn't happen overnight
unfortunately and I think that you know
the people of Egypt just have to
continue to fight they need to continue
to fight for the freedom they need to
continue to fight for their freedom of
speech and I thought you know it was
really great that Youssef how do you say
he's awesome he after he was released
from jail he actually went on to
continue to express what he really
believed and I have his quote here and I
thought it was very poignant he said if
there is anyone who has insulted
religion it is those who use Islam as a
weapon for political reasons so he's
going to continue to be him and I think
that's great he's going in the in the
right step in the right direction in the
right step so bill as a comedian is
there anything that you won't touch upon
that you think is actually too sacred to
really hit on well I think funny is the
that that's that's the bottom line but
also within that you know I guess have
certain personal standards that I
I don't I don't need to go beyond but
the bottom line is it is it funny and
and all you know what's a bill Santiago
personal standard line is it is it you
know the c-word is it the n-word it
spits look if it's in context it's not a
certain word but it also depends how you
arrive at it you know I mean it's clever
enough it almost justifies anything you
know it depends who you're going after
are you going after the are you going
after the victim are you going after the
power structure are you reinforcing
stereotypes are you shedding any new
light or really you're really getting it
off your chest you know are you going
for the lowest common denominator making
everybody feel good about you know the
stereotypes that they feel like
prolonging for a forever so you know I
have my view on things and then I use
the the punch lines to get it out there
but the first is is it funny does it hit
me as funny - I think it's funny and
then you know hopefully other people
will tell well well said and Bill
Santiago will be headlining at the
chuckle hut weekend you might be sharing
a it's funny good this reminds me is and
I I was in Cuban I went to a comedy
festival there and you know Kasia was
still very much in in power at the time
and I was I was so interested like what
can you get away with it yeah when the
fact there's no one knew what the line
was like sometimes they're looking
sometimes they're not sometimes some
will get carted away so you never know
they're always pushing the limit you
know and everyone on stage at night at
any moment no matter what they were
talking about could have been arrested
for for an indefinite amount of time
yeah they're just wrong about the
charges I definitely like the idea of
having the comedy police taking away the
hack it would kill the clubs again I
think that's what we need actually for
the yeah well know for the comedy scene
in this country yeah
for every once a while somebody must be
dragged lost babe I mean it would fill
the clubs you know right now we are
hurting for audiences and you have to
sort of know what should actually be
police Jenny like when Lenny Bruce when
nobody was gonna be arrested he would
somehow do and he was doing the best of
course then died of a heroin overdose
but you know we've all got promises
let's talk about the biggest comedian in
America literally and figuratively rush
limbaugh actually this is bizarrely good
news related to rush he has sort of come
around and is now accepting that gay
marriage is going to happen in this
country
he doesn't really back it himself but he
now sees it as in it an inevitability
tough word but let's listen to Rush
so my conclusion that gay marriage is
inevitable was simply in recognition of
what the political story said the
Republican Party wishes it would go away
and that didn't by that they mean the
Supreme Court issue a sweeping ruling
legalizing in all 50 states if the
primary source of pushback isn't going
to push back on sorry it's inevitable
inevitable
there you go doesn't sound too happy
about it Matt is it inevitable and if
you've won Rush Limbaugh have you
actually won the argument well I think
there are two different two different
answers to those questions one I do
think it's inevitable and I think you
can really gauge the community you know
the community consensus on it at this
point that there's just been the
velocity of which people you know the
people the people have people have
adopted this view of the last it's a 18
to 24 months it's pretty unparalleled
and even it's in 2008 you didn't feel
like the tide had really turned and that
it was starting to spread into you know
kind of the voters and the the people in
the populace are in between the 40-yard
lines but it was still more of you know
cut it's still more a play of a of an
interest group and so I think that you
know just taking the not Rush Limbaugh
perspective you can see that you know
it's if anything is going at this rate
and you know
at this rate it's going to you know
eventually the holdouts are not going to
be able to stem the tide any longer now
putting that placing that up against
Rush Limbaugh and why he's adopting this
view I think it's really just a common
Rush Limbaugh tactic of exasperation and
that he's throwing his hands up and
showing how exasperated he and the other
traditional Americans are with you know
how everything's going to hell and how
basically good wholesome Americans have
been put under the spell of these
liberal interest groups and whenever he
gets to latch onto that you know he
really hits it up he really hits that
home because just kind of solidifies you
know the kind of cultural leanings of
his audience and that's all those are
only people who really cares about he's
not looking to appeal beyond his
audience so adopting this view it allows
him to do so
without looking like he's so [ __ ]
that he can't see what's right in front
of us yes Sam is there anything worse
than these liberal interest groups that
just want equality for their liberal
basis it's unbelievable to me especially
because when you look at what surprises
me about Rush Limbaugh's even you know
prior to the statement when he talks
about the sanctity of marriage he's the
last person to talk he's been married
four times so you know that to me is
just absolutely surprising and and and
you know like you said I mean I don't
think I think marriage equality
shouldn't be a political issue it's a
human rights issue so sure rush limbaugh
and and other people that are
conservative or are very religious you
can have your opinion you can have your
belief and say listen I do not agree
that same-sex couples should be able to
marry that's fine I respect that I
highly disagree with you but to then try
and govern an individual and say that
you do not have this right to get
married like every other human being out
there that to me is immoral yeah bill
when we look back what once gay marriage
is legalized whether it takes two years
or five years or ten years when we look
back on the people like Rush Limbaugh
and the Rick Santorum's and the Michele
Bachmann's and that whole gang well we
look back on them the way we look back
on people that were for segregation back
in the 50s is it going to be that level
of scrutiny III I think it all depends
on what
not rush actually comes out and gets
married to another minute yeah maybe
that's why he's giving up baby that's
why he thinks it said never maybe it's a
personal choice he thinks the fifth wife
will be of the same gender first yeah
maybe so you don't think that we're
gonna look back at all we're gonna look
back at all that footage absolutely yes
yeah a very hilarious mashup just a few
years yeah
do any of you guys think that this thing
isn't gonna happen in the next you know
in the short foreseeable future two or
two or three years no I did two or three
years at tops I you know it's odd that
there's a real distinction between I'm
31 every generation below me starting to
probably anyone who's 28 and younger and
this is second nature to them and I just
I I think you rarely see you know
culture kind of cultural norms evolved
at this rate and I think you know gay
marriage and the acceptance of
homosexuality over the last few years is
you know real outlier not in a bad sense
but you know it's I think the
Republicans realize the thump some of
the part of what's going on with Rush
Limbaugh is that he sees that the
Republican mainstream and the
establishment is trying to pawn off a
lot of their recent failures on him and
he knows that this one this would be
easy father for them to say look you've
got the Rush Limbaugh's you know making
us lose the youth vote because they're
railing against gay marriage and now he
gets to kind of buttress that a little
bit funny that you know radio hosts have
to sort of act like politicians because
you're right he's playing to the base
the same way he's signaling the base you
know he's letting me know to give up on
the to give up on the issue because
there there's no way they can survive as
a party unless they unless they do
really interesting backpedaling going on
there I went on some of the forums and a
lot of his fan base including himself
there's like an another updated
interview where he started a backpedal
because his a large part of his fan base
was saying no this is this is you know
this is against the Bible this is
against religion and it's so funny
because they're so quick to use the
Bible and certain aspects of it that
suit their agenda because you know
there's other out worldly things in the
Bible like you know you should send your
firstborn daughter into slavery so it's
like it's it's there they go ahead and
they pick and choose which agenda it's
we preach even it so literal so I
thought it was interesting though
watching him kind of do like an update
within the forums because so many people
did not like that he was kind of you
know lifting up his arms and saying this
is inevitable yeah well rush if you do
officially officially get behind gay
marriage you would be the biggest star
in the gay bear bars of West Hollywood
and I think it'll be great for you
alright let's stick with the gays for a
minute it's a hot topic these days there
are reports that a gay NFL player is
going to come out sometime during the
next season and you know now players are
saying oh you shouldn't do it you know
the media what's gonna happen blah blah
blah I personally think that the guys in
the locker room will be ok with it most
people as you're talking about the
trends and the younger people and most
of NFL players are relatively young I
think the players would all be okay with
it or most of them at least I think that
the problem is that the media will make
such a circus no matter what that that's
actually going to be what keeps people
in the closet do you think somebody's
gonna come out this year and if so who I
don't know you know I mean I really I'm
not I have no skin in the game so to
speak I'm not I'm not a football fan I
don't say why did matter I'm not a fan
of marriage either and you know it's
just sort of weird to me like that that
that there's so much of a push for
marriage which is a defunct obsolete
institution that more often than not
ends up in complete failure I wouldn't
want to have a part of it myself they
you know there was such a push to get in
the military I wouldn't want to have
anything to do with that myself NFL I'm
not a part of it either so like if
everyone in the NFL
were you know like Iraqi vets who were
married to each other it wouldn't I
wouldn't it wouldn't affect my day at
least you know so I mean that's where I
you just want to sit in a cold dark I
want nothing to do with any of them and
I don't want marriage I don't want a
military Sam what do you think is it
gonna happen this year and they ready I
do hope it happens I do think within the
NFL community I think the players
themselves will be accepting of it I am
worried about people outside of the NFL
community I mean a lot of the fans you
know generally speaking are I mean we
look at football and football is
affiliated with you know red-blooded
heterosexual males rawr and I just I do
sympathize with its it's it is really
hard to come out all together it's hard
to come out in the entertainment
industry but does it happen already I
was surprised there's been retired
players but there is he is going to you
know if a player comes out yes would it
break down a huge stereotype yes would
it be fantastic yes would he get a lot
of acceptance from people that support
gay rights and I do think from the NFL
and the players but I know that he would
also get a lot of discrimination too in
my opinion from some of the fans yeah
how much of this do you think is going
to depend on the players skill level
because on one hand I could see it if
you're if you're a guy that just made
the team well you don't want to wrangle
any chains you know and risk getting cut
if you're a mid-level guy you it's
you're in that same thing where you just
want your job and if you're a star well
then you're risking all these
endorsements follow us so how much of
just the the actual physical athletic
part of this is going to affect who does
this well I think that you have you know
that plays into another really
interesting point that the NFL seems
like the oddest league for this to
happen because it's the most it's the
most capricious because you don't have
guaranteed contracts so it's actually
riskier for an NFL player not just
because they for business purposes not
just the cultural ones to come out but I
mean my my prediction is that it's not
just going to be one player why would
one of these players come out themselves
they're gonna tan them up with other you
know players that they know that are
active and they're going to
in a group why wouldn't it would make
perfect sense you kind of diffuse all
that pressure but here's the other thing
as far as acceptance in the locker room
is I think people would be beyond
shocked to know how many people within
the game know that they have Katie gay
teammates and know who's gay and it's
completely yeah and I mean same thing a
lot of the other kind of sacred cows and
masculinity like gangsta rap I mean
there's an iconic gangster rapper that
everybody in the industry knows is gay
and it just somehow doesn't so I think
that listen you're always gonna have
because there's a large NFL players
coming from a large geographic expense
you're getting a lot of people who came
from parts of the country that this is
still not except one but guys that just
don't want to get you know involved in
something that it's still attached to
sex and fortunately I have a friend
who's a pro football player and we're
talking about something on Twitter and
he's like man I gotta get off Twitter we
lost big today and one that you could
not imagine the type of what we were -
you know we had brushed up on like you
know internet commentary for political
shows Pro pro athletes on Twitter the
venom they get when they have a bad
performance or lose and so we're gonna
lose at some point when they lose and
they can they take the punches yeah well
that that's a perfect segue to how I
wanted to end this which is how much of
this actually just has to do with the
fact that because of all our phones and
Twitter and Facebook and snapchat and
everything but if you were gay and on
the DL snapchat that's what the kids are
using right I wanted to get one how much
you know like I know John amici who was
the former NBA player who came out he
said he was going to gay clubs when they
would play the Knicks in New York but it
was before everyone had a phone so how
much of this do you think is just
someone who's just going to get caught
flat out caught in a loop and yet yeah
during that we are always on our phones
wherever we go and it's so easy to take
a picture yeah but
apparently there is a gay underground
that I'm not involved in that it's
incredibly good at you know they're like
Batman and Bruce Wayne just in their
day-to-day life and they have amazing
ninja tactics and they've they've been
you know these pro players have been
able to utilize those thus far so if it
hasn't if they haven't got caught thus
far I think they're gonna be voluntarily
coming out and I think it's gonna be an
ensemble not just one guy often they're
dressed both as Batman and Bruce Wayne
all right let's let's move on enough
with the gays let's talk about
everybody's favorite TV grandmother
Barbara Walters it was announced last
week out of nowhere deadline.com said
she was retiring they said she was given
up the view all the ABC gigs etc etc and
then the weekend passed and then Barbara
jumped on the view and said not so fast
let's take a look so there were many
reports last week saying that I was
retiring from ABC and there was an
assumption that I would be making an
announcement today and the paparazzi was
outside of my home interesting life
however Here I am and I have no
announcements to make
but if and when I might have an
announcement tonight I would do it on
this program I promise
and the paparazzi guys you will be the
last to know yeah all right I guess it's
gonna take a little longer for me to
replace Barbara at the view
guys what what's everyone's fascination
with the view first because I feel like
not a week goes by that we don't hear
something about those five crazy ladies
bill what do you get I don't know it's
just become an institution right it's
the first show of its kind but you know
and they've been able to keep it an
all-female institution so I guess people
go there for for that voice but you know
it's such a cushy job for her like I
thought she was retired she's basically
been retired just like an old woman
showing up and talking and it's like she
was 83 she looks great for 83 yeah and
people say oh come on just leave
peacefully I would leave peacefully it's
her show she started it she still you
stay in that new stay Barbara yeah what
do you guys think though about this idea
that the network's I mean this is
happening with Leno as we speak that the
network's seem to be like leaking things
and it's also with successful things
because Leno's ratings are still the
best and they're raking in the dough the
view is one of their most profitable
things over at ABC so why is it that the
network's have this like self-fulfilling
prophecy that they want to destroy the
things that are making them cash I don't
know I don't know if it's a publicity
stunt I don't know I one of my favorite
parts of the report was that they were
waiting for her publicist to go out of
town
give me a break like honestly Barbara
Walters she's a very strong independent
woman she's successful the view is her
show she's going to leave and retire
when she's damn well ready and you know
what like you said she disappears for
like months at a time from the view I'm
from ABC special she's not there day in
and day out you get the chicken pox a
couple of months if she was gone for
like two months with the chicken pox
yeah the chicken pox took her out right
so I mean they can do whatever they want
but I don't think they can force like a
Jay Leno or a Barbara Walters to going
to retirement if that is the case I
don't buy it but if that is the case
like people are speculating I mean Jay
Leno and Barbara Walters are here to say
yeah do you think these networks just
have this bizarre or is this just all
publicity I mean it's
just more publishing it's difficult it's
difficult to tell if you know this is
just something that's gonna get a bunch
of staplers throughout it in turns heads
and people are just screwing up and
leaking the wrong releases or if this is
you know the in turn back of
Machiavellian hatchet job by Whoopi
Goldberg or God knows what and but you
know the you've always have to account
for the possibility that networks are
trying to create tension and publicity
in a very odd way and that they're stars
are in on it completely and we all know
that you know nikki Finke and Deadline
Hollywood they're no stranger to this
and you know I think there's Barbara
Walters we all choose in too far too
powerful a position at that shown with
ownership to be pushed aside with you
know non voluntarily so this was either
a big mistake and got a bunch of people
fired or it you know it was done
completely choreographed and Bob iger's
sitting there laughing his ass to her
announcement today yeah yeah I mean it
was the first everyone was talking about
it all weekend right we probably had the
most eyeballs come back late today what
do you guys think though is this just
you know is Barbara she can't go
anywhere unless she wants to as you're
all saying but are they are they leaking
this because ultimately they want to go
younger so you sort of put it out there
then she has to respond and then it's
like that's your way of sort of edging
around just you know publicity stunts
for a little uptick in in in ratings you
know but I don't think anyone really
wants to see her go the only reason it
would like this here it goes because I'd
be it doesn't seem like what kind of
what type of Conclave is convened in
order to pick her successor it would be
such a huge big deal to see who do the
celebrity interviews make them cry she's
like the only one that can do that but
she might have retired from those things
now say she's not going to do those
so all right so my last question on this
is there anything forgetting
entertainment and networks and all that
in 2013 in America it is loyalty to your
company or your company's loyal to you
loyalty to you is that does that exist
anymore no we're all just out it's gone
gone I can't really trust anybody and we
work for the same company
okay very good
all right let's move let's talk about
pornography because yes this is the
internet and as I said earlier most
likely you have another tab open right
up there and we know what you're doing
this one's a good one
Pasadena City College is going to be
offering a course in porn they are not
going to be viewing porn in the class
thankfully but they're going to be
covering such topics as why we love porn
clearly we'll start with you all so
they're gonna be discussing why some
people are deeply disturbed by it and
then how to make decisions about porn in
your life and how to have conversations
about porn with others so let's have a
conversation with porn bill clearly
you're very deeply disturbed yeah by the
fact that this has now entered our
academic you know syllabus as porn
fasten your well look I think more than
anything else that Dee legitimizes all
college education the fact that people
are paying are you using student loans
till I go to this classroom I mean who
is Sonny I wouldn't want to be in a
class with anyone who would take that
class that's okay cuz here's what I'm
okay I actually get the class I get it I
wouldn't want to attend the kawaii do
you get it I'll tell you why I actually
think that the class is a good idea now
I wouldn't want to take that class just
because I do think that it's going to be
a whole lot of curves and I don't want
to sit next to them however from a
sociological aspect or even a
psychological aspect to look and see and
dive into this subculture which is let's
be honest I mean porn is a subculture
it's a cultural
phenomenon worldwide so many people
watch porn so many people are addicted
to porn people are you know marriages
you know break up over corn so there is
really what's that whatever happened so
you really can look into it and see you
know what exactly is why is it being
seen as deviant I mean I know when I
studied sociology at UCLA we would look
at you know prisoners we look at a lot
of different little subcultures and
figure out what happens to them when
they're in society and how they're
looked at in a deviant way and I think
this is why China is outpacing us and
why why do you think people do get so
obsessed with it they're more urgent
things that need to be noted in China
they're teaching the economics of porn
and we're consuming all the born it'll
we're borrowing money from China
have you seen recent courses not once
have you seen recent courses recent
courses at universities because I don't
know and how much of people charm paying
for these courses it's ridiculous to get
his porn card in writing was on the wall
um you know first was we were just
discussing the sanctity of you know a
liberal arts college curriculum went out
the window you know a decade ago at
least but it brings up another really
interesting point about education is
that you have to have stuff like this
now this goes in the brochure the porn
class goes in the brochure and what
attract other students that wouldn't go
there for engineering or something uh
yeah to attract you know any kid you in
a city college I think I think you're
having your bridge toric discredit see
retire but that's not the way it works
anymore and there was a really it was
really interesting it was a it was how
the a rock climbing wall was an allegory
for how why colleges why the cost of
college is undergoing so much
inflationary pressure in that you have
to have stupid [ __ ] like a rock
climbing wall now you cannot have to
have stupid [ __ ] in order to attract
students to an education I think there's
no way
we're due no no it's over this is it but
this isn't of course that the
prerequisite for an engineering degree
it's necessary for colleges to be viable
financially you need this stuff now you
need a little so what's next work house
just gonna compete how is Harvard and
Yale and pretty hair gonna compete and
you're the most fired up about it you
have a little fire and brimstone
Republican anyway you picked up on
something about this this is a stupid
idea but I think you traditional I think
you picked up on something which is that
port has become so big in this culture
but we really don't talk about it we do
joke about it a little bit but it is in
on everyone's computer it is there all
the time so a class like this actually I
think could do some good having people
depending on I agree with you if it has
to do with if you're going to get I mean
you have to take a whole lot of
prerequisites your first two years in
college so if your degree is going to be
in psychology if your degree is convene
sociology I do think that this is a
course where you can dive in and look at
this culture and see why is it such a
phenomenon now of course if you're gonna
go and become you know an electrical
engineer if you're gonna go you know be
pre-med yeah this is probably you're
just a pervert and you want to come in
this class do you think it makes you a
pervert if you're if you're in another
if you're studying for it's okay the
medical condition that this could leave
you final thought on higher education in
pornography okay um you know first the
way you described the class is really
interesting because I think if you would
if they had couched it in these are the
negative effects of porn you could get
away with it and it would sound like a
really you know worthwhile and
substantive class right because and I
think it's a better do that's it to make
that just one aspect of the class but
then you know just talk about the
broader cultural impact of foreign um I
think that that makes it really
interesting but it leaves it vulnerable
to be looked at
pawn as as you know as not as fluff but
you know we've got if you looked at the
syllabus in the the offered courses of
so many like well top-notch colleges I
mean you know I would assign up for
philosophy of the Simpsons but tomorrow
all right
good talk good talk I want to remind you
guys that the Rubin reports official
outfitter is bonobos comm dig my shirt
you can get it for 20% off go to bonobos
calm and use code TR r20 and that brings
us to our final topic pre-crime it's not
just in Minority Report scientists have
found a way to predict whether convicted
criminals are going to commit another
crime it's a little technical here but
basically they scan the anterior
cingulate cortex the ACC in ninety six
prisoners and the area in the brain
that's associated with decision-making
they found often was smaller and they
followed these convicts for about four
years thus finding out that many of them
did cause repeat crimes so my question
to you guys broad topic here is
everything that we've ever seen in
science fiction going to destroy us
because this is Minority Report one of
my favorite movies and are we all going
to suffer from science fiction and
everything that has been in every moment
have it any other way
no hey science fiction writers saw this
stuff and were able to write about it
because they they saw it as a
possibility I mean this is Clockwork
Orange to a tee I mean Anthony Burgess
that's what it is you know trying to can
we figure out how to you know impact
free will enough when fruit will runs
afoul to stop crimes from being
committed and that movie obviously had a
lot to say on the topic and not
everything was you know crystal not a
lot of crystal clear conclusions but hey
I think and I'm not an alarmist about
like you know about technology and
everyone bitching that some you know
Zuckerberg owns them because he knows
that they purchased something off but no
bows thank you but um this starts to
concern me because you could there's so
many other factors and so much other
data that you could use to correlate you
know a production for crime and you
think about it and one thing that a lot
of people never touch on is that crime
has gone down a lot over the last 20
years or so so the same factors that
were you know that were at play 20 years
ago are at play now and some of those
people didn't commit crimes so how do
you reconcile that and how do you
whatever solution that they're gonna
generate from this new data and being
able to predict this how trying to apply
it and without completely destructive
effects I couldn't even imagine it yeah
so where do you think this puts the
nature versus nurture argument if you're
just predisposed to be a criminal then
is that it then should we be locking
people up no I think I mean even the
study alone if you you know if when you
continue to read into it there's some
links to just the in-depth analysis of
the study and of course you know at the
end of it even though they did find I
think it was almost you know double the
amount of the inmates with like the low
activity of that part of the brain for
like the actions and the decision-making
they did find that that there's other
variables in place too of course this
wasn't a perfect study but they saw it
could be contributed to too much
caffeine it could be like loose
variables and then of course there's the
nature versus nurture did they grow up
in poverty so there's so many variables
it would take a really long time and a
whole lot more science to really break
into that study and make sure that you
know that it is perfect variable free
before they could implement this into
the prison system and aren't there a ton
of just sociological things such as or
socio-economic things such as if you
grew up horror and were given a worse
diet and had less nutrition that that
does affect your development and your
brain and all that is it specifically
decision making that's the target that's
supposed to equal future in crime well
what predict what party you're very much
I make very bad decisions but they don't
lead they don't lead to you know
somebody actually speaking of the poor
thing haven't they proven that when
you're watching porn like a certain part
of your brain actually is shrinking like
it's actually feeding endorphins there's
something and he lost his train of
thought as we were all that porn clearly
um yeah a lot they're not that I'm a
neuroscientist even though that's how I
got on the show by telling you that way
yeah yeah there's certain there's
certain parts of the brain they're just
associated with pleasure and stimulation
you know aggression and they cover it
that's really interesting that they
cover a lot of the same ground between
violence and sex and you know it's
probably an indictment of the entire
male gender that those are the things
that that kind of shape our goals but
we'll just push back suicide no there
won't
no women having poor decision criminal
thoughts is that what that would be very
interesting that would be interesting to
know whether there was actually some
data there that was worth talking about
there's nothing there really there that
that makes this study any more
sophisticated than just like confident
did we didn't we get a word like
phrenology was proven wrong it's nice
right like in your world you can't you
can't you can't tell by the shape of
someone's head whether or not they're a
bad egg is that right it's interesting I
think I thought what are you what I
thought was interesting about the study
because for the people that they did
follow the four years after yeah and
they were able to see and yes there were
other variables like I say there were
the the caffeine like random variables
that could have contributed to it but in
the end they did see that the people
that were reoffending did have
significantly less activity within that
area of action and decision-making
so if they could perfect eight years
down the road it could be twenty years
whatever I think that would be
incredible like I said before carefully
speaking if it was variable free to be
able to see which criminals are going
reoffending which aren't that would be
an ideal situation and then Tom Cruise
gets part to a movie everybody's happy
all right well you guys have all proven
that you're using the big part of your
brain quite well so I'm gonna let you
pimp yourselves out to the good people
Matt you're up first
ah Wow talking about myself where can
they find you online are you on the
Twitter find me on on the Twitter at at
Matt belinskiy the ili n s KY right
below you right now and that's will help
with the spelling I'd hope AIT people
know I'm good yeah okay so the team IT
people know me you can follow me on
twitter at sam shocker
and then you can also watch my show here
at the young turks network called pup
trigger and bill santiago you skeptic
pro-russian boy lunatic you got my
number bill Santiago calm if you want to
know more information will be at the Ice
House a lot this month is this airing
this month
this is airing which is which is in
Pasadena so luckily it's very convenient
to won't be taking the course that's
right looking you bashing the city move
everything else alright I thank you guys
for watching and we'll see you next week